NARRATOR: You've spent years hearing about
advances in AI, from programs that beat
go and chess grandmasters to smart
assistants--
WOMAN: Hey Alexa, play my coding playlist.
NARRATOR: --and facial recognition--
MAN: I ruff you!
NARRATOR: AI is changing how we live.
Now you're ready to take the next step and
learn AI yourself. You know where you
want to go but you don't know where to
start.
That's why we built the AI programming
with Python Nanodegree.
In two months or less you'll build your own AI
application using deep neural networks
from scratch. Learn all the key AI skills
in one place such as Python, linear algebra,
and deep learning with Pytorch.
And get the support you need for success
with mentorship and project reviews
our AI experts. So what are you waiting for?
Join us to start building your AI
skill today!